this is what the future of Life off the
earth looks like
the Moon is a fully developed commercial
hub and weigh station for traveling
deeper into space anyone who wants a
truly Out of This World vacation
destination can now look to the stars
and back down at Earth the first
permanent Settlers of Mars arrive to
self-building habitats that produce air
water and food with a new generation
destined to be born on alien planets
this is the next step in our Evolution
as a species
well this is the coolest thing I've done
in a long long time today scientists are
blazing a trail to this very future this
is just a remarkable structure from an
engineering perspective I want to know
what breakthroughs are being made water
can be used as Rocket fuels so we could
use the moon as a refueling station that
is a big hairy audacious goal that will
Forge a future to
Reserve Life off Earth
[Music]
thank you
my name is Justin Shafer and I'm an
environmental scientist
if I was a kid growing up on the south
side of Chicago I've always dreamed of
exploring space when it comes to the
very expensive Prospect of sending
humans to live in space many people ask
why should we go
but as someone that's concerned about
climate change in the health of planet
Earth should we be thinking about moving
to another home if so how will we
actually build an outpost on an alien
planet and then survive the lethal
environment of outer space
I'm in Columbus Ohio to meet someone who
knows firsthand
former NASA astronaut Dr Catherine
Sullivan
Kathy was a truly inspirational figure
to me I was an intern at NOAA the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration the first time we met it
was then that I saw the possibility of
being an astronaut as something that was
very real
incredibly this Prospect seems possible
in my lifetime
to find out just how and when Humanity
will accomplish this
I'm catching up with Catherine my old
Mentor
I just remember listening to you speak
it made me want to be an astronaut it
made me think that it was actually a
feasible thing well thanks that makes me
feel really good
Welcome to our planetarium whoa
project things on this donut will take
you anywhere in the universe
is a geologist deep sea Explorer and was
the first American woman to walk in
space
she knows a thing or two about life off
Earth
you spent a lot of time in space right
my total is like 23 days Catherine flew
multiple shuttle missions during her 15
years at Nasa once you're in orbit have
effectively no weight to be able to sort
of drift in the air like particle dust
is pretty magical but space is dangerous
a vacuum devoid of atmosphere water and
oxygen everything we need to survive you
think the human body as is is designed
to tolerate space for years decades
there are definitely some unknowns and
some ifs about that if our bodies are
not sensing a gravity field the calcium
in our bones which gives our bones their
strength it starts to Leach out not only
that absent protective gear long-term
exposure to radiation damages DNA and
can lead to cancer can certainly lose
your life in space and you've got to be
aware of that and clear-minded about the
risks of it much of what we know about
these dangers comes from studying the
long-term inhabitants of space stations
orbiting Earth
NASA astronaut Scott Kelly spent nearly
a year on the International Space
Station or ISS as a result of this
Mission Scott experienced cognitive
decline damage to his eyes and even
changes in his DNA
before we can attempt to build permanent
bases on the moon or Mars we're going to
have to figure out how to protect our
bodies and Minds from threats like these
but where there's a will there's a way
Mars now is I think like the moon was in
the 1960s a big hairy audacious goal I
definitely think exploring Mars and
figuring out what would it take to get
there I'd love to see us do that
I think it's really wired into human
nature to be exploring to not explore
our place in the cosmos to not continue
to expand our understanding
at the largest scale of where we live
and our place in the universe I think
it's just short-sighted three two one
[Applause]
with so many unknowns surrounding the
welfare of humans in deep space NASA is
first setting its sights on a return
trip to the moon
the Artemis Mission scheduled to launch
by 2024 is the first step towards
establishing a permanent human Presence
at the Moon with the ultimate goal of
using it as a springboard to the red
planet
a spacecraft orbiting the moon will
serve as a hub for research on the lunar
surface
the goal is to learn how to live and
operate on another Celestial body while
proving technology is necessary for a
mission to Mars
but at present lifting people and
materials above Earth's atmosphere is
extremely expensive
to build a moon base we'll need to find
cheaper methods and reusable equipment
I'm in Colorado to visit Sierra Nevada
Corporation who is working with NASA on
this heavy duty problem
to Sierra Nevada Corporation home of
Dream Chaser wow it's beautiful
John Curry is the director of The Dream
Chaser project the Dreamcatcher is a
space plane so it's just like riding on
an airplane landing horizontally in the
runway as you know the space shuttle
through 135 missions and worked very
well
what makes Dreamchaser different is it
is so much cheaper the space shuttle was
just too expensive to maintain or
lighter weight we're stronger than
shuttle the dream chases clever design
and carbon fiber body allows it to hold
enough cargo to supply astronauts on the
ISS for half a year
with Innovations like these it can be
flown 15 times before maintenance
keeping costs down
the space shuttle required maintenance
after each launch
with the retirement of the space shuttle
in 2011 the Dream Chaser is now the only
spacecraft capable of delivering people
supplies and science experiments to the
ISS and then navigating back to Earth
for a gentle Runway Landing it can also
perform the whole mission autonomously
without a pilot I believe this vehicle
is going to be critical to transporting
humans to and from space on a routine
basis
Sierra Nevada plans to conduct six ISS
resupply missions by 2024 and unlike the
shuttle which launched aside two
boosters in a fuel tank the Dream Chaser
is designed to be launched into orbit
Wings folded atop a rocket
so what's the top speed something like
this would reach orbital velocity is 17
500 miles an hour Dream Chaser will
circle the Earth 16 times a day at this
speed but when it returns and enters the
atmosphere it practically has to grind
to a halt what's cool about this and
very Innovative about this design is
this is called a lifting body meaning
the lift that you get from this vehicle
is actually the body itself rather than
the wings
unlike most planes dream chaser's actual
body not its wings takes the full force
of the air pressure the underside of the
Dream Chaser is wide and flat and pushes
against the atmosphere to slow re-entry
probably the biggest risk for Dream
Chaser is the entry because you see 3000
degrees Fahrenheit coming back through
the atmosphere to get to the ground so
you've got to make sure that this
vehicle can survive 3000 degrees
Fahrenheit
the Dream Chaser can land anywhere there
is a ten thousand foot long Runway which
means it can return to any major airport
in the world
for the Artemis moon mission NASA is
looking at a radical technology to house
the astronauts inflatable habitats
these habitats will connect to a core
power module dubbed Gateway Sierra
Nevada designed a system called the
large inflatable fabric environment or
life that can dock to the Gateway module
we have a module you could actually turn
into a space station and that would be
what you would want to take to the moon
the habitat can be folded in a compact
manner for launch and then later
expanded in space
once connected to NASA's Gateway module
inflatable habitats will serve as a base
for researchers traveling to and from
the Moon the key elements to get us to
the Moon is we have to put the
infrastructure in place to make sure
that people can actually stay there once
you've got that then you have a
permanent presence in space
Technologies like these are forging the
path for humans to build a permanent
home
off Earth
in the future inflatable lunar habitats
prove safe and reliable gateways to the
moon's surface on a weekly basis
researchers shuttled between the Moon
and Earth on Advanced space planes with
enhanced rocket boosts travel time is
reduced over the 400 000 kilometer
Journey from four days to just one
with the completion of a permanent
research base on the surface of the Moon
space agencies approve both the base and
the orbiting station for commercial uses
space tourists can even enjoy a one-week
stay
with inflatable habitat technology
permanent presence on the moon might
become a reality sooner than we think
but with virtually no atmosphere further
exploration of the lunar surface will
require new technologies to protect
explorers from the sun's lethal
radiation
the last spacesuits designed to function
on the moon were custom fabricated for
the Apollo Astronauts more than 50 years
ago these suits were both expensive and
cumbersome
I'm in Brooklyn New York to meet Ted
Southern the co-founder of final
frontier design
his company is developing the next
generation of spacesuits designed to
overcome these limitations
this is pretty cool this is where we
make space suits generally doing
prototyping of Suits we work with NASA
and commercial space industry to make
suits work better
this is an Eva suit extra vehicular
activity so this is when you leave the
vehicle it's like a spaceship for one
person
in the days of Apollo spacesuits were
only worn for a single Mission final
Frontiers designing reusable suits that
are flexible lightweight and durable now
NASA's talking about going back to the
moon but for a lot longer period of time
so they want suits that are more mobile
that won't wear you out and that can
last longer there's no reason for a
human to go to the moon or Mars unless
they can get outside and walk around
the key to surviving extreme
environments like this lies in the
pressurized Eva suit it's like wearing a
basketball which is where the challenge
of like how do you get a basketball to
fit a human being and how do you get it
to move like a human being
pressurization is essential to surviving
in the vacuum of space without it blood
would fill with bubbles and the body
would puff up to twice its size
causing death in less than two minutes
but pressurizing the soup to protect the
wear from the harshness of space creates
a problem with agility
so you lose a lot of dexterity dexterity
tactility range of motion all these
things are really important we actually
have a tool that allows us to test the
gloves without having to put on the
whole seat oh really nice check that out
yeah
final frontier won a prize from NASA for
their Superior pressurized glove Design
This is a pressure chamber and there's a
pump underneath that will pull gas out
from the chamber stick your hands in
through the ports the chamber is
designed to create the same extreme
vacuum of being in space we're at about
4 PSI lower than ambient you're
approaching NASA's Eva Space City
pressure
okay so this is the problem that
astronauts have exactly almost feels
like I have a robot hand yeah I'd really
appreciate it if you solve that Rubik's
Cube too
let's see
you think that there's anything wrong
how these things should be designed for
people yes
spacesuits are traditionally built Like
Big Bubbles theoretically there are
garments that could tighten around your
body equivalent to the gas that you're
breathing which would be much tighter
fitting potentially more Mobility that
could revolutionize how spacesuits work
we're going to let air back into the
chamber
oh wow that definitely changed very
quickly but that's not the only problem
they're solving Moon dust is sharp and
very fine-grained the particles get
everywhere and can cause
life-threatening injury if inhaled
final Frontiers Eva soup has a unique
feature to prevent this from happening
the rear Port can dock directly with a
landing craft or Rover is this like an
entrance on the on the back side is that
that's right yeah you get in through the
back this will allow an interface with a
suit Port so you can be inside your
Rover and jump in the spacesuit without
bringing dust into the Rover it's also
easier on the astronauts to get in and
out this way NASA's current suits you
get in through the waste and that means
you have to really wiggle in this work
your shoulders yeah and there are a lot
of astronaut injuries from Suits but one
of the most major ones is shoulder
injuries from getting into getting into
the suit
Ted's got a surprise for me he's letting
me try on the pressure suit which is
something that usually only astronauts
get to experience right now we have air
flowing in through the umbilicals here
on your chest the only place it'll come
out of is right here as your regulator
you can kind of push your head back
with my pressure balanced it's time to
experience with walking on the moon or
Mars might be like
walking around in that
I have no I think I have no joints right
now yeah I'm like a tin man
[Music]
well this is the coolest thing I've done
in a long long time I don't know if I
heard anything cooler than this
with advances in new flexible protective
suits like these
okay welcome back the path to exploring
other planets seems clear
[Music]
in the future Eva suits for space
exploration are as flexible and
comfortable as wetsuits
tight elastic undergarments apply stable
mechanical pressure against the skin
eliminating the need for air
pressurization
these suits also compensate for lower
gravitational pull allowing scientists
to explore just as easily as they can do
on Earth
[Music]
even with protection from the harshness
of space astronauts won't survive a week
on an alien planet without one Living
Essential
water
but the cost of bringing enough liquid
water from Earth to support even a small
base on the moon or Mars is astronomical
this means if we're going to establish
outposts in space
scientists must find a reliable source
of water elsewhere I'm near La to meet
Dr Dean Bergman at honeybee robotics
honeybee robotics is developing
cutting-edge tools to help NASA find and
extract water on the moon or Mars
nice why don't we go look at some cool
things all right
we are developing these Technologies to
be able to create a sustainable
civilization off of our planet
what is the most precious resource in
space just because we can use it for so
much and the more we can collect the
more ability we have to really live off
world and on other planets
in 2009 NASA confirmed the presence of
water on the moon in the form of ice
some estimate more than 100 million tons
might be found under the surface at the
moon's South Pole
not only will future space-faring
Pioneers need this water to drink and
grow food
this essential liquid has another
potential important use in space
by splitting water into hydrogen and
oxygen both of these molecules could be
used as propellant for spacecrafts
water can also be used as Rocket Fuel so
we could use the moon as a refueling
station on the way to Mars potentially
honeybee's drills were sent to Mars on
multiple missions to determine what was
below the surface
in 2002 the Mars Odyssey Orbiter
detected large amounts of water ice
beneath the surface
so in 2007 NASA launched the Phoenix
Mars Lander to search for
we were part of the Phoenix Mission the
idea was to uncover the ice of the poles
of Mars so we would scratch a line on
the surface and uncover the ice wow this
is a powerful thing to be in the
presence of
in the Phoenix Mission discovered what
they were looking for the first direct
evidence of Frozen water on Mars
in 2018 the European space agency's Mars
Express Orbiter discovered liquid water
for the first time beneath the South
Pole region so honeybee is developing a
method to extract the liquid water with
this the Trident drill with planetary
volatiles extractor or pvex
and Vince vendiola is showing me how it
works so this is honeybee's large vacuum
chamber it is a one meter by one meter
by three meter tall thermal vacuum
chamber P of X is a coring drill with
integrated heaters and electronics to be
able to capture water from lunar ice
very cool stuff
the large vacuum chamber is used to
recreate the same low pressure
atmospheric conditions found on Mars
Let's Do A Drill test close the chamber
here
we go I'm going to lower the foot pad
onto the surface
this hollow core drill can dig into the
lunar or Martian underground and collect
water ice and icy soil meters beneath
the surface
the percussion sound is our cam spring
mechanism which gives us an additional
weight on bit which is kind of like a
space Jackhammer it's like a space Jack
Hammer and our software is designed to
where we only percuss when the system
detects that you're drilling into
something hard it'll be save a lot of
energy so it is taking your core sample
right now right so we capture our sample
force and then we activate heaters
it's a process to extract liquid water
on the moon or Mars
first the heaters must vaporize the ice
then the vapor will be collected within
a cold trap and convert it into solid
ice for storage
without this system the liquid water
would instantly evaporate and be lost
all right is there water in there now
we'll see what we got okay open up the
chamber
[Music]
into the Epic reveal
area
[Music]
nice this is the future right here
the red planet has plenty of ice some
buried just inches below the surface
using this technology to extract it will
make a future life of Earth possible
in the future Advanced robotic drilling
technology sets off a gold rush in space
entrepreneurs race to prospect asteroids
and comets across the solar system
autonomous probes mine these celestial
bodies for precious metals and water ice
once the ice is converted into Rocket
Fuel it is more valuable than gold
trading posts and weigh stations emerge
across the solar system to process this
Precious Cargo and further the
exploration of space
with a large source of water ice
identified on Mars booting a long-term
base there sounds more and more viable
but what other problems will scientists
need to solve before people can live in
a hostile environment on missions that
could stretch for years
yeah we are definitely on another planet
right now
I'm in a desolate part of Wayne County
Utah
here it certainly looks like Mars
I'm heading to the Mars desert Research
Center to meet Commander Mark Levesque
in his and his team
[Music]
let's head on upstairs
all right
hey folks Rich we have a a nice
International crew here
this habitat serves as an earth analog
of an early manned research base on Mars
it contains the essential components a
future team would need for a long-term
Mission including living quarters
Greenhouse science labs and
observatories there's a variety of
research that goes on here psychological
geological astronomical
the water parched extremes of the Mars
desert research station or mdrs make it
perfect for simulating a mission on Mars
this is one of the closest analogs to
Mars on Earth given the landscape given
the isolation given sporadic
Communications
at the mdrs every effort is made to
simulate the challenges conducting
research in a hostile alien environment
any outside activity such as exploring
the area or conducting projects out
there we have to be in spacesuits and we
have to go through a depressurization
for five minutes in the airlock science
time
okay just we're going to take two Rovers
with this and these two guys are gonna
go in the second river Roger that uh
hello Hub this is Aries one that starts
entering the airlock now
leaving the airlock
[Music]
have airlock is secure
a primary scientific objective with the
first research mission on Mars will be
searching for signs of Life past or
present
people have been preoccupied with
finding Life on Mars for centuries
in the 19th century while mapping the
red planet with a telescope Italian
astronomer Giovanni scaparelli saw what
he thought to be water channels
many believe they were artificially
constructed canals built by Martian
but with the arrival of the first
mariner missions to Mars in the 60s and
70s scientists confirmed that there was
not an advanced civilization
however recent discoveries of geological
formations have excited them about the
possibility that some form of life could
have once existed
I just want to get out now all right
so we're heading for that folder on the
second Peak
the geology surrounding the mdrs is
comparable to what the first researchers
on Mars were encounter just
to answer the question of whether
primitive forms of life existed on Mars
future researchers will look to rocks
by peering inside these rocks they may
find the presence of biomolecules or
even fossils of microorbs
foreign
we're at the top of kissing camel Ridge
we're gonna Mark the Spot on our GPS how
I can give you the quiver for tonight
four two four nine five four zero
yeah this is the spot for gypsum
gypsum is a mineral that exists on Mars
as well
in 2011 the Mars rover opportunity
discovered veins of gypsum in the Rock
beds because gypsum forms in the
presence of water on Earth
scientists believe that bodies of water
once flowed on the red planet
the team here in Utah is simulating this
search
we're gonna keep our eyes open when it's
covered in mud no one knows what it is
on Earth gypsum has a practical use it's
used in the home in walls and plaster on
Mars it could also be used for building
new habitats
some on these clay
yeah here's some gym tonight Shelly
we've got a little right here
something's nice and clear and pretty
and some is really cloudy
so we'll just Mark the location on GPS
and then analyze them back at the lab
sounds good
[Music]
by examining the gypsum in its
surroundings on Mars scientists might
one day find evidence of life and prove
it also evolves on the red planet
back at the lab the team processes and
examines the stone
part of the interesting thing about
being in the simulation is you start
thinking through like well what would we
need for this and what would we need for
that
but on Mars everything has to be either
with you already or you have to like cut
up cans to make it work all right but I
can imagine when you first visit Mars
you're going to have to have Scrappy
operations right there's going to be
stuff that you're like gonna have to
make it work and this is definitely a
great practice for that
[Music]
while some team members are working out
the technical challenges of life off
Earth others are studying the
researchers themselves
PhD student Rich Whittle is studying how
humans behave when confined for long
periods of time in Aerospace
environments like these well we're
looking at here in particular is the
psychology of cruising isolated combined
environments we're looking at Sleep
Quality profile of moods positive and
negative effects
being cooped up in isolation drive
people crazy any Mission to Mars would
involve being away from Earth for years
a one-way trip alone takes about eight
months and the first habitat likely
wouldn't be much larger than the space
capsule's tiny quarters so I guess this
is one of the rooms right there
this is very humble and
it's probably the uh the deluxe Suite
the commander Suite oh you can see light
this is luxury man I know I'm feeling
guilty
Mark has experienced the psychological
impact of living in isolation first hand
I mean Mark was done to win her over an
hour ago yeah at South Pole yeah so
three months oh no a year oh wow it's a
challenge you're locked in with people
you can't leave that kind of confinement
sort of forces people apart
towards the end personality conflict
started to come out
one of the longest Mars mission
simulations took place in Russia
called Mars 500 six volunteers were
isolated for 520 days they even
simulated the up to 20-minute radio
communication lag between Earth and Mars
The Experiment showed that prolonged
confinement led to sleep disorders
fatigue and depression
before the first crew can be sent to
Mars for the Long Haul space agencies
need to figure out how to overcome the
tedium personality conflicts an
emotional toll of extended separation
from loved ones Crews going to Mars will
be trending together for at least a
couple of years so they're going to work
out the Kinks are going to find out how
to work together because that's that's
the real key in any kind of situation
like this with more simulations like
this we'll definitely be able to solve
the technical and psychological
challenges of establishing a base on
Mars and Forge a path to the future of
life in space
in the future researchers at the
international Mars base make a
remarkable Discovery a particular Rock
specimen completely changes the way
Humanity thinks of its place in the
universe
the sample confirms that ancient fossils
similar to those found on Earth also
exist on Mars This Rock reveals that the
complex forces that cause life to evolve
are not uncommon
in principle life possibly even complex
and intelligent life may have evolved
Across the Universe
while the first research station on Mars
is likely to be small and Scrappy a
long-term base with dozens or even
hundreds of people will need more in the
way of complex facilities and buildings
however transporting the materials to
build large-scale heavy-duty habitats
from Earth is unfeasible
how can we build a permanent Outpost
using what's already on the red planet
I'm in Brooklyn New York to meet a
design team with a unique solution so
this is Mars ice house that's a habitat
that's a habitat Rebecca pales Friedman
and Michael Morris run the
forward-thinking firm space exploration
architecture also called search they won
NASA's International Mars habitat design
competition
what we do is we design habitats for
humans to be in outer space we use
indigenous materials materials that are
native to the planet and we create a
beautiful living experience that's also
functional for the astronauts but that's
easier said than done than the red
planet's lethal environment
the primary goal will be to protect
against radiation from both solar rays
as well as Cosmic Galactic rays
the best material to protect against
radiation is actually water which makes
up most of our atmosphere and Mars does
have plenty of water ice to work with
on Earth We're largely protected from
harmful Cosmic radiation thanks to our
thick oxygen-rich atmosphere and
magnetic fields
but with barely any atmosphere the
surface radiation on Mars is hazardous
high energy particles from the cosmic
rays damage human DNA and can increase
the risk of diseases like cancer
so like our atmosphere protecting us
here on Earth we thought why not build
an ice house
we created this double shell structure
for additive protection but also to have
a bigger space that is so cool part of
our objective was like if we go all the
way to Mars why should we live in a cave
or a concrete bunker people should be
able to look outside look at the you
know the strangeness of the landscape
but they should also receive the
daylight which is very similar to our
own here on Earth they have 25 hour days
and they have about 50 percent of the
light that we receive here on Earth
but a long-term settlement will need
dwellings that are more complicated than
what can be built with just ice the
search team has a mind-blowing solution
for that too
using the mineral-rich Martian soil or
regolith
this is Mars ex-house X house the
objective was to build with Martian
regolith or concrete
we mined the exterior shell from the
soil and we mine the interior pressure
of bubble out of high density
polyethylene that we drew from the
atmosphere so it was like to be mining
the sky and Mining the soil to create
one building
another crucial Innovation is that this
habitat is constructed before the
astronauts arrive it's built by the time
they get there and then when they get
there they can just do the work that
they need to do and the team is devised
when far out method for building these
prefabricated dwellings remotely all the
buildings that we've been designing are
all 3D printed wow that is so cool
search's plan calls for construction
robots to be sent to Mars in advance
to build the habitats using 3D printing
technology there are no construction
workers on site we have to anticipate
everything that could possibly go wrong
and design that beforehand
but these incredible structures aren't
just computer models
the design team is working with
state-of-the-art 3D printers to make
versions of them in real life
using a mix of materials similar to
Martian soil the printers build actual
freestanding versions of searches
structures the future of this
breakthrough technology is much closer
than I could have imagined we will be
building a habitat on the surface of
Mars by 2028. incredible and so that I
know that doesn't sound like clothes but
that sounds pretty close to us I mean
and that sounds incredible to me that's
absolutely amazing
Innovative designs using materials found
on Mars will pave the way for the first
settlers to arrive to move-in ready
homes
but what will happen when the supplies
they brought with them run out they'll
need food and oxygen to survive in this
alien hostile environment
for humans to create civilizations
anywhere in space we'll need to build
self-contained and self-sustaining
ecosystems that work like our home
planet but how can we build water cycles
and farm in desert wastelands like the
moon or Mars I'm outside Tucson Arizona
where researchers have been conducting
Decades of groundbreaking research to
achieve this ambitious feat this is a
grand experiment in Earth Sciences
started about 30 years ago trying to
understand how the Earth Works they
decided the only way they could truly
understand how the Earth controls itself
is by creating a facsimile of it this is
called Biosphere 2 as we live in
biosphere one
[Music]
Dr Joaquin Ruiz is the director of
biosphere 2.
it almost reminds me like a palace not
like a laboratory or research
environment but more like a science
Palace can you tell us about what's
going on here in high level sure right
in front of us is the rainforest to have
a big ocean and then you have a desert
it was an audacious idea build a
small-scale version of Earth and
completely closed quarters
in a matter of years they recreated a
wide array of ecosystems that originally
took billions of years on Earth to
evolve
to succeed Biosphere 2 needed to be
completely self-contained and sealed off
with nothing brought in or taken out
our air
we're recycling everything in 1991 eight
volunteers of biospherians lived inside
Biosphere 2 for two full years like a
future habitat on Mars Biosphere 2 had
to be perfectly thought out and highly
engineered the health and safety of
future explorers depended on its success
any habitat on Mars will need to remain
completely sealed off from the toxic
environment that surrounds it but
keeping it sealed and structurally sound
is a near impossible task sudden changes
in internal air pressure could destroy
the structure itself so the engineers of
Biosphere 2 came up with this Innovative
solution called the lung and deputy
director John Adams takes me inside
we're going into the lung of bias for
two and when it was originally
constructed they designed it to be
hermetically sealed but they knew that
they had to deal with changes in
pressure and this is a device that they
came up with to compensate for that
whoa
this is just a remarkable structure from
an engineering perspective I didn't
expect to walk in and see this the lungs
are connected to the rest of the
biosphere by a series of tunnels to
continuously balance the air pressure
inside what we're standing inside of is
an extremely large diaphragm and that
diaphragm helps to modulate pressure
inside the facility is it has a
counterweight an aluminum dish flexible
rubber membrane the combined weight of
those two is forty thousand pounds and
the only thing that's keeping it up in
the air as you see it right now is
differential air pressure wow
that is pretty insane
this weighted rubber diaphragm regulates
the Two basic kinds of air pressure at
work as the temperature outside heats up
the air inside the biosphere warms and
expands
inside the lungs the increasing air
pressure pushes up against the weighted
flexible diaphragm
without the diaphragm's flexibility the
air pressure would shatter the glass of
the sealed habitat in space an incident
like this would be deadly
as the air in the biosphere 2 pulls and
contracts at night the weight of the
diaphragm presses down by reacting to
the changing of air pressure the
biosphere 2's lungs continuously adjust
applying the right amount of force to
keep the air pressure even throughout
the closed system habitat this is where
air travels back and forth as we
modulate the pressure changes within the
facility
on the red planet temperatures can
fluctuate more than 100 degrees Celsius
over the course of a single day which
means a feature like these lungs is
essential to any future Mars habitats
and to sustain life these habitats must
cycle and recycle the air for humans to
breathe and also grow plants for food
on Earth this process links animals and
plants animals breathe in oxygen and
breathe out carbon dioxide plants absorb
that CO2 and discharge oxygen in the
biosphere this fundamental cycle is
recreated with the rainforest
researcher Laura Meredith is conducting
an experiment to test its resilience
all right so I'll show you the
rainforest
[Music]
so this is almost 30 year old tropical
rainforest
beautiful yeah it's nice even three
weeks into drought it's pretty green
some of the trees are dropping their
leaves the soils are drying out but
really you know I think this rainforest
is showing us that it has quite a bit of
resilience
in the rain forest plants absorb humans
waste carbon dioxide the inhabitants
breathe out this subsequently helps the
plants grow and in the process also
creates oxygen for the inhabitants to
survive growing a stable resilient plant
ecosystem will be essential to the
survival of any future inhabitants of
the moon or Mars
however the first biospherians weren't
so lucky 16 months in the oxygen levels
dropped precipitously it turns out there
was something the original designers
underestimated
microbes microbes in the soil and in
Biosphere 2 Cement absorbed more oxygen
and released more CO2 than originally
estimated nearly leading to disaster
fortunately for the biospherians they
intervened and used additional Machinery
to pump in oxygen
in space an oversight like this would be
catastrophic which is why it's important
to simulate and fully test a system like
this before building a biosphere on
another planet because it's a closed
system you really need to understand how
your ecosystem works
biology is really incredible in its
resilience and that's something that you
would really want to have as a component
of your ecosystem on another planet can
we create a closed living system like
this one on Mars it's an immense
challenge to put together all the
complex components but I am sure that we
can create one
thanks to the original Founder's dream
Biosphere 2 is a reality
and while this living laboratory has had
many challenges Biosphere 2 is providing
crucial insights into ways Humanity can
build self-contained ecosystems
it's Innovations like this that will
Forge a path to Future long-term
settlements on the moon or Mars
I think it's really going to take
entirety of society's Focus for us to
really start Expediting the process of
getting people to Mars
but I think one of the things that a few
scientists brought up that I spoke with
was this idea that we should focus on
keeping our home here habitable and not
trying to run to other places
some argue why spend billions of dollars
to get to Mars when we could be using
this money and Ingenuity to solve
existing problems on earth like poverty
disease and climate change
should we flee this planet we can't
figure out how to live wisely and live
well on this planet I think we've been
given quite a treasure here in this
little Third Rock From the Sun
but Catherine also thinks humans are
destined to set foot on the red planet
someday I think it's certainly
technically possible to have a
sustainable habitat on Mars and it's
very it's conceivable that it could
happen within the next couple decades
the technical challenges are pretty
immense it's going to take thousands of
people to work on this and concentrate
on it at the same time but we feel that
it's important that humans see these
planets firsthand and we will actually
we'll learn more others look at the
greater good that can come from new
breakthroughs it's not going to be cheap
it's going to be difficult and we're
going to need to push towards a common
goal to get people to Mars and hopefully
Beyond eventually and every time we are
able to accomplish something like this
we can then bring that technology back
to Earth and the more advanced these
Technologies get the more advanced the
Technologies on Earth get and I think
that's hugely beneficial and the
discovery of life elsewhere in the
universe could have a profound impact on
Humanity I think the odds of us being
the only life on the universe is very
low I think there's life somewhere so
that's again why it's critical for us to
actually continue to explore to continue
to look outward because I do think who
eventually we're going to find somebody
else
as a scientist that's long dreamed of
exploring space
I'm excited about overcoming the
challenges that will lead us to become a
truly space-faring civilization
beginning humans on Mars and settling in
a civilization I'd love to see that in
my lifetime
will I see it in my lifetime I'm pretty
sure
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you